[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
aujourd'hui on avait un moment donné ont
connu une accalmie dans la fabrication
et la circulation les fellows avec les
nouveaux enjeux géostratégiques
notamment les situations difficiles
entre le mali et ses anciens partenaires
et la probable arrivée du groupe vag le
russe il ya beaucoup beaucoup de choses
qui circulent aujourd'hui
[Musique]
là
non
aujourd'hui la diffusion de ces
informations ni via des réseaux comme
moi tu simple qui a une forte
pénétration au niveau des populations
rurales qui ont une très faible capacité
de vérification de l'information le
connexion avec le reste du monde dans
les pays comme le mali par exemple à
l'intérieur du pays où vous avez une
opinion qui est formé sur la base
d'information fausse à partir de watsa
qui soit des formes mais aussi à lancer
des situations qui n'existent tout
simplement pas
laissera pas être président
penser qu'il aime le même
puis aucune chaîne européenne en parlera
à la vie d'un malien n'est rien devant
ces occidentaux
sont tellement
mattera sophistiqués ils font des vidéos